President Trump has made a landmark
historic decision to recognize Jerusalem
as Israel's capital but that's of no
concern to many in the mainstream media
instead they're freaking out about
whether the president slurred a few
words toward the end of his speech and
using it too as they've been doing for
some time questioned his fitness for
office he seemed like he was almost
hanging on to the prompter and destroyed
going there was there was a struggle
happening
we don't have updates on his health we
don't know what's going on Donald Trump
is not in perfect health there's no
reason why that person should have that
ability and we as Americans don't know
whether that person has the physical and
mental capacity to function correctly we
should apply that standard to the media
at times but when the Hillary Clinton
looked woozy and unstable remember that
during the campaign and even ended up
falling at one point a lot of them sang
a different tune I want us to be very
careful here the way in which we're
reading her health and how that can
serve as a proxy right for the way in
which we were talking about gender today
the news media lost its mind and Hillary
Clinton's health became the most
important thing in the world this idea
now of attempting to cast doubt on
Hillary Clinton's health I mean she uses
pillows which is a dead giveaway that
she's at death's door the double
standard is so patently predictable but
this effort effort to question the
president's mental fitness it's getting
totally out of hand
joining us now someone who knows what it
takes to command General Wesley Clark is
a former Democratic presidential
candidate and former supreme Allied
commander Europe of NATO and great to
see you general what do you think about
that now president Trump had some pie
some I don't know some throat or teeth
problem there obviously when you watch
the video and we're jumping to he from
one day it's his dementia the next day
he's mentally unfit what are your
thoughts well you know president's
Health's a big issue and it's always
been a big issue for presidents do you
think that's fair because he had some
bridge work felt like was pres
before most people were born here I
remembered I was a little kid he had a
heart attack and he actually had to lay
off duties in the Oval Office for a
while and it was a big thing so there's
always been media interest obviously had
a dry throat or something with like
bridgework or something it's like it
happens it's like it's convenient but as
you said it's not a double standard it's
the same standard it's do they went
crazy they don't the Democrats
Republicans who hated Trump went crazy
when anyone raised an issue of Hillary
Hillary was actually falling into a
limousine and then disappeared for how
long was that it she disappeared for
some time remember on September 11th and
we were not supposed to talk about that
she actually fell okay and that wasn't
the first time she problem look at at
candidates and president's health and
people whatever they say it's no big
deal people that are opposed they use it
you know what they there's no worry you
know what they told me when I ran for
office general Charlotte Carly he said
he was my boss when I was in the
military
now Charlie said he said I would support
you he said but why would you want this
job he said before you run people will
try to keep you from taking it when you
have the job people try to keep you from
doing the job and after you've had the
job you spend the rest of your life
defending yourself so everybody
understands it's highly partisan it's
always been that way in American history
from George Washington Andrew Jackson
time meltdown over in general this is
what was this is what's happening the
American economy is soaring you know it
I know it people are more optimistic
retail soaring we're reestablishing and
reasserting ourselves as focusing on
America first we're still working with
other countries we're redoing some of
these trade deals things are looking up
and so the Democrats have to go to
identity politics Trump's mental Muller
investigation identity politics Trump's
mental Mulder investigation that's your
party are you proud of that party well
that's the part I'm basically a military
guy Laura I did run for president I'm
you know I believe got it run is very
important
but here's the thing when I talk to
Democrats and I am a Democrat because
that's where I'm registered there when I
talk to the press they say they can
hardly wait to run on the tax bill as
it's emerging good so they've got the
tax bill they've got health care they've
got education but as an American how do
I feel about it I'm really glad to see
the economy doing well I'm glad to see
low unemployment it's responsible for
that I would be accredited I think
Donald Trump gets some credit for the
atmospherics I think Barack Obama gets
some credit I think George Bush and Hank
Paulson get some credit for official
yeah George W Bush that's great for the
economy when it was falling apart in the
fall of 2008 in the middle of that
president election the big bang who blew
the whistle and he got his Treasury
secretary Hank Paulson did something so
you know are we stronger than we were
when you were astir Warren you were and
when you were in NATO compared to the
time that you were NATO to today America
was richer back then
sure Millett we were more powerful as a
nation because we were less in debt
China was not as powerful and not as
strong so you fast forward about 20
years you know today America is 20
trillion in debt China is on the rise
all over the globe Isis is still out
there the establishment lost hold of
this whole thing
that's why Donald Trump was elected if
look if things were riding high the
economy was going great and Donald Trump
wouldn't have been a factor but he was a
factor because the establishment never
held up a mirror to themselves and saw
that they traded our manufacturing away
they didn't they didn't take care of
their people first and Donald Trump said
look I'm not a politician that's what
I'm gonna try to do you know it's the
way democracy works when people think
things aren't going right they want to
change now we can go back and we can
dispute about exactly what happened if I
go back and look at it I look at it like
how come we had all those tax cuts in
2001 2003 because no let me finish
a George W Bush as president said I'm
giving you back your money he did but he
did it in the middle of a war and so we
spent a lot of money happened before
9/11 remember 2001 and 2003 two tax cuts
and do you want the government a hang
more
my eye I want responsible fiscally
responsible smart gonna get so much
about bushel but that's a good thing
about the war in Iraq night was a
mistake yeah no kidding and you were for
it and I was for you so I thought for
the war in a row let me go through the
quotes you said you probably would have
voted for it do I'm gonna go so do I
really have to pull up my research
another quote is for president because
the war was not going well at the time I
probably would have voted for it but I
think that's too simple a question
it is so did you say that or not general
why I would have voted for it because
voted for it Bush it gate no that's not
the point the reason I said we're not
relitigated nobody raised it you have to
give me a chance to answer or so you can
vote for the president to have authority
to give him greater negotiating to learn
I got it and that was about it was about
roaster he's not going to walk you and I
agree on the war we shouldn't have gone
in I was four at the beginning
ambassador to Israel Obama's ambassador
to Israel mock the heavy breathing
coming from the critics of the move
would it whose side are you want on this
was a good idea for Trump to do what he
did or no you know what reflects
domestic policy and domestic politics
for Donald Trump so it's a good idea for
him politically and a lot of foreign
policy is derived from your political
base so it's a sort of a natural move
the question is now having sort of
shaken up the region now can you take
advantage of the shake-up
so I say three things have to be done
okay quickly number one is the Saudis
have to displace the Iranians got in the
support of Hamas and D legitimate Iran
as the big protector of Islam number two
is the Bibi needs to say that no more
settlements until we get the peace
agreement no more illegals and number
three Donald Trump needs after these
other two he think that way by the way
the Palestinians can have he's gonna
have more success than your former boss
general it's great to see